let me ask a difficult question that
needs to be asked here
can uh SpaceX continue uh its successes
without Elon
this long-term Mission to Mars
I I think the discussion about Tesla and
autopilot or Robotics are in your link
with main computer interfaces is a
question wholly separate from the SpaceX
question because there's a lot of other
competitors
doing
some different but amazing engineering
that Tesla is doing in both autonomous
vehicles semi-autonomy or full autonomy
and obviously in vehicle design and
electric vehicles there's a lot of
people that are doing incredible brain
computer interfaces but while there is a
lot of competitors to SpaceX and we'll
talk about many of them they're doing
amazing work it seems like he's really
driving progress here over the past 10
years what do you think about that
okay the first thing I think
to remind people is just how many
brilliant people do work at each of
these companies obviously yes you know
elon's had the some of the best teams
assembled ever just incredible people he
knows this he he will gladly tell people
and he says it often like the amazing
people the amazing teams here so it is
important to remember that
um that being said like there is
something to elon's
just super far forward not taking no for
an answer on things approach that and
and
almost to his dismay I think
he is afraid of the sunk cost fallacy so
much that it almost almost gets to the
border of like being you know like throw
out everything before it's even we've
we've known her enough at the same time
like it moves the needles so fast so far
so as far as the question of would
SpaceX continue to like succeed and be
able to ultimately go to Mars without
Elon the Mars thing I think would
probably be hard to uphold without it I
think a lot of that drive from Mars is
from Elon
um it is maybe too Fantastical for the
average person and the average employee
and maybe the average CEO that might
step in it have a company's Mission be
to go to Mars like it's just or even
governments yeah clearly because like
you said the Mars plan was non-existent
for NASA yeah still really there isn't
much you know so
I I think if how many people I'm sorry
to interrupt how many people are talking
about it's obvious that we need to
become multi-planetary right there's not
I
there's the Mars society and the like
serious leaders of engineering uh
efforts yeah or nations and so on yeah
which it does seem if you think about it
that it it's obvious yeah and the grand
eventuality it is obvious of the of
human civilization this whole human
experiment we have here we should be uh
expanding out into the cosmos 100 so I
think the big mission if we're measuring
SpaceX spacex's success on getting to
Mars or not I think they'd have a really
hard time
um continuing to fulfill that drive
without Elon at the helm
um now I think there's a certain balance
and beauty of Elon specifically when it
was Tesla and SpaceX where Elon will go
in you know have mild tornadoes around
the factory and the the engineering you
know and like mix everything up and and
things get sometimes just totally thrown
together you know and and totally just
like get it done just to to get it done
and start moving that direction and then
he'll leave and go do that same thing
you know at SpaceX or Tesla vice versa
and then there's a little bit of a calm
where people come back in and they fill
in those gaps you know and I think
that's kind of always been a pretty
healthy thing honestly is like I think
if he is too focused on on any one thing
it almost is like he'll spin too much
you know like it's like like too many
tornadoes yeah too many tornadoes and
and I think it could almost be like you
need someone to come back in and like
you know like backfill almost because
I've heard definitely stories of like
like well probably a good a good example
would be last
um last well was that last year two
years ago 2020
two yeah was that yeah or no 2021 they
did a the First full stack of the
Starship super heavy and they called it
the big surge all of a sudden like
thousands of SpaceX employees you know
came down to Starbase and they just
started building like you wouldn't
freaking believe I mean it's just things
going crazy it was actually in the
middle of that first interview I did
with him was in the middle of that surge
there was like commotion like you
wouldn't believe you couldn't hardly
talk because there's just so much going
on people just welding and blah blah you
know everything they did during that
period was basically scrapped
because it was just not done very well
but they got a fully stacked Starship
rocket out on their launch pad
you know and it it set it I think at
some point you kind of have to stabilize
some things enough and just say like
this is what we're doing to catalyze
some things and say now do this it's
almost like do it for fake not do it for
real almost it's funny because through
that time because I had a lot a lot of
conversation with them I think that
process was hugely stressful there was a
sense I don't know where that sense is
today but there's a sense that Starship
is going to be very hard to pull off
yeah that's still borderline impossible
to pull off and then and that was really
wearing heavy on him and the team and
everybody yeah so like to have this
chaos of development is fascinating yeah
big time and I think they really had to
push
you know if they hadn't done that if
they hadn't done that big push
you know we might only be now seeing a
rocket stacked for the first time
um you know it might be a lot more
finished rocket a lot more High Fidelity
a lot more flight worthy rocket finished
and and stacked but
um and they might not have to walk stuff
backwards but the same time like you do
have to in this world you do have to
push really hard uh to make rapid
iteration and Rapid change in progress
so it's it's interesting I don't know